[Applause]
i see what you did there the analytics
and all tell me you just love showcases
of power in anime flexing as they call
it and who doesn't those moments are
some of the most awesome moments of
coronation and anime can give a
character that's why i'll be giving you
a gift today today our video is going to
be on this year's top showcases of power
in anime and i hope that you're prepared
for it prepared to be both amazed and
for some spoilers mind you you're gonna
need it
our first entry for the day is rengoku
fighting the demons in the train no this
isn't either of the boss fights but this
really does give off a strong first
impression how can aspiring students
like tanjiro and friends not be
impressed this guy just sensed his way
through all the demons tricks before one
shotting them all in short order in the
process he even showed off some of his
moves most notably rising scorching sun
or while giving some bad ass boasts of
his own what a way to make an impression
even asleep he can't stop being a badass
his survival instincts alone allow him
to power through enmu's pawns and lead
the comeback his tenure in the show may
not have been very long but man oh man
did rengoku make a very fiery impression
in it flexing and giving us some of the
most visually spectacular fights ever in
both cinema and tv anime you'll be miss
rengoku now i wanna know what an
alternate timeline would have looked
like where he survived and became
another big mentor figure for tanjiro
is it just me or does this give some
overlord flashbacks in terms of insane
otherworldly abilities and such rimirou
already has the title of most
overpowered 2021 characters locked up
however actually seeing it is something
in itself and we get a glimpse of it
when he unleashes megiddo seeing rimaru
in rage and just giving zero dams is a
scary thought taking on the mantle of an
executioner he coldly eradicates 5 000
people just like nothing a deeper look
at the mechanics behind megiddo will
reveal more of how amazing the ability
is but let's just say that i didn't
expect wiping thousands out with the
great sages super calculations to look
like this i mean i just don't see how
you assert dominance more than just
chilling and sending low-tier water
spirits to commit mass murder it must be
a completely awful feeling being in the
middle of that and all of that comes
back to one thing we're all merely just
insignificant insects in rimaru's world
all will fall beneath his might and this
video just proves that
[Music]
this year's been a good one for one
piece we're in the midst of a rocking
arc featuring the mighty kaido but
before that we've got what people have
called to be an ultimate team up on one
side we've got luffy teaming up with
lauren kidd and on the other side it's
the beast pirates as they say though
unnamed mob characters all fought on
mass especially against heroes much less
guys as strong as the worst generation
well there's really no tension i mean
come on do you really think luffy and
the boys are gonna lose him i've got to
give some props to the animation it also
makes seeing the worst generations
powers look so awesome seeing the panels
in manga is one thing but actually
seeing it animated completely gives you
a new perspective and we're all left
staring at all heck do they even need
each other each of them can take down a
whole ship by themselves it's quite a
funny thought though when you think
about it
[Applause]
next is stringer fighting in day armor
does this also count as the best one-man
army moment of the year too i kind of
want to crown it already you see
castlevania at season four has been
nothing short of awesome and whilst
there's more to it than the fights and
action sequences it's moments like these
that truly send it over the top feast
your eyes on this eye-popping sequence
of stringer just destroying everyone in
sight it's as brutal and violent as
you'd expect and i don't think maximum
carnage would be enough to describe the
destruction she released on everyone the
action's fluid the choreography is on
point and you can really feel the impact
every time she swings that large sword
of hers an awesome moment as one of the
audience a truly harrowing moment though
if you imagine yourself in that scene
people have been calling this the
berserk adaptation that we needed and
never got and you know what they're
right
[Music]
tokyo revenges makes its way to the list
with mikey versus valhalla do you
remember the most overpowered characters
list i had just recently make sure you
go and check that one out now the reason
i brought that video up is because
mikey's featured there and if you want
the most concrete evidence that he
belongs in the list of the most
overpowered 2021 characters then you
have it right there thorman vs valhalla
has a lot of intense moments of
straight-up no-holds-barred fighting
between gangs and it's exactly the kind
of stuff you'd expect out of tokyo
revengers most notable in it however is
that for me it serves as one of mikey's
many shining moments in the show you've
got to admire his resilience here even
when it seems he's down and out he still
finds a way to push his resolve and turn
the tides with a straight-up devastating
down on the enemies now this just proves
that while he's someone that dolman
respect and take pride in for his
strength his power goes beyond the
physical combat abilities it's pretty
much impossible to take the fight out of
him and that alone is scary to think
about are you enjoying this list so far
yeah then make sure you hit the
subscribe button it helps the channel so
much and it will help the channel get to
its next milestone let's go take it home
and reach a million subs at some point
next year remember each subscription
matters thank you for your help now
let's get back to the list
villain fights intrigue me because the
dynamic that they employ yet both are
bad guys that you won't root for
typically but there's always the more
charismatic and the more likeable one
that you'll be rooting for in this case
is shigaraki who has a tough matchup
ahead of him well on paper at least hey
reed estrogen gave shiguraki a run for
his money at several junctures but once
shiguraki's quirk evolves and he finally
grabs hold of that peak power it is all
over it's all shigaraki as far as i'm
concerned and he makes rudestro the
first victim of his ferocious
counter-attacks it's a chilling moment
when shigeraki completes his resolve but
i can't help but feel in order to see
his evolution complete in such a manner
melting down an entire city is something
i tell you this is shigaraki's crowning
moment the very time we know that he
means business he solidly cemented
himself as the ultimate villain and the
one capable of following his master's
footsteps our heroes have a tough battle
ahead if they want to even sniff a
chance of beating this monster
after that we have levi versus zeke wait
is this the correct season hold on a
second yeah yeah yeah it is indeed
remember how levi actually destroyed
zeke before yet the poor slob just keeps
coming back for more doesn't he with a
quite healthy dose of fear this time and
yet again levi flexes his power on zeke
almost effortlessly in fact this time
it's not a meticulous breaking down of
zeke like in season three zeke doesn't
even want to fight levi at this point
but you know levi doesn't care well it's
even less of a fight than before it's
still one hell of a moment that will get
your heart racing the image of levi
falling down unfazed before killing off
his comrades turned titans is an
underrated highlight for me unfazed and
unworried all he had was sorrow in
having to solo destroy them all and that
he did levi is not the strongest soldier
for nothing and even after he's proven
that again and again in so many
instances he hasn't lost his touch one
bit all the way to the final season levi
remains a human super weapon and that my
friends is pure awesomeness
how about allstate just squashing dead
end like it was nothing yep this belongs
to the list alright one of the most
gripping scenes in this season was a
rudius getting the doughnut treatment
and that's courtesy of austen's
effortless destruction of the group the
fight itself is good to be fair you can
enjoy the masterful animation of the
group's futile struggles against the
dragon god but i never really felt the
dead end had a chance nothing they did
manage to as much as deal damage to
ulster and it just swats everyone away
like bugs they never had a chance and
austin's more than happy to show that
fact in their faces seeing the defeated
dead end after the fight was such a
painful scene and the fight well if you
can call it that did so much in building
up hype over austen's power my
shin
finishing up the list is holo purple
anyone saw jiu jitsu kaizen become the
hit of its season i did and it did so
mostly because it brought something to
the table something you might say the
push demon slayer over the top well it's
no contest if you'll compare the two in
terms of popularity let's just say that
amazing animation and jaw-dropping
moments in a shonen series that's
relatively easy to consume is a formula
for success now i'm saying that because
what i feel is one of the best moments
of all in jiu jitsu kaizen came in the
form of gojo finally joining the fight
with his spectacular hollow purple this
comes in the midst of yuji and toto
having won superbly animated battle
against hanami the fight's already good
and i've talked about the insane
animation of fight progression on
another video but having gojo come in
and finishing it with a show of power
man it's just the series being given the
justice that it deserves what more can
be said of gojo's power after this
moment it's clear that he's the type of
mentor who's not going to be jobbed out
anytime soon just to feed some villain
hype and he's probably the strongest
person on the side of good period do you
think hollow purple is the flex moment
of 2021 share your thoughts in the
comments section i'd love to know your
thoughts about this one perhaps you've
got something else in mind as well i'd
love to know that too if you like the
video then hit that like button and
check out the rest of the videos from my
channel you can also support me through
patreon and channel memberships as a
last thing i'll leave the link to my
instagram so you can drop by for some
news related to anime and my channel
that's it for this video hope you have a
great day and i'll see you again goodbye
[Music]